look good afternoon everyone
um I have to really say before I respond
to the debate what a joy it is to be
here today an absolute pleasure and I
get the sense from each and every one of
you you know thank you to Peter thank
you to David thank you to Claire
everyone for really bringing us together
because we are stronger together as
we've just been hearing actually from
Paul Holmes but we're stronger when we
speak in a United Way and we support one
another and that's effectively what CDO
is all about and I for one am totally
energized by being here today
um I do just want to pay tribute to our
speakers this afternoon in the debate
we've just heard you know with the Gusto
and conviction that we've heard from you
know speakers ranging from Alex to Kane
to Andrea to Mimi and also rmps as well
um answer Stephen you know people who
are at the Grassroots the party is in
safe hands quite frankly and the ability
to speak carp and openly is really what
we should cherish and value
in the conservative party so I'm
thrilled to be here I really am and I
cannot thank everyone enough for making
this happen and for CDO the value and
purpose of CDO and there's so many
points that I do want to actually
respond to I'm going to start off
naturally with the Grassroots because
you know like you all I've been around a
few years now
um in the party I've been an activist
for only about 34 years this is where
you can all say you don't believe that
at all
um but you know I'm proud of being an
activist I'm proud of my membership of
the conservative party I've been a
member of my entire adult life and the
Joy about today is not just that we're
back here in Bournemouth you know Conor
and others mentioned the joy of
Bournemouth and conferences you know
party conferences like this where we
engage where we reach out where we
absolutely have the right kind of
discussion because it is so far removed
from the Westminster bubble and look
what the Westminster bubble has done for
us over the last 12 months which is
another discussion in its own right
which I will come to shortly but it's
because of you that we're here it is
because of you the conservative party is
that most successful democratically
elected political party in the world
people write books about us right about
how successful we are and that's because
of you because you are the heart and
soul the backbone of our party we've
heard it again and again out there the
pouring rain the cold delivering
leaflets in freezing cold Winters
campaigning in successful general
election campaigns where we win ACC
majorities you're the ones organizing
the fundraising events week in week outs
and the famous Raffles as well and I'm
always there if you want a raffle gift
um but you're on the front line in terms
of getting conservatives elected and
there are some important points about
this you do that not because you're paid
to do it or for public City or for
self-promotion you do it because as
we've heard again and again and again
today you believe in our party you
believe in our values and our ability to
transform Britain for the better to be
on that mission to spread Freedom
Enterprise and opportunity across all
parts of the UK and Beyond and I know
how hard you work I've had the greatest
privilege in recent weeks and months of
campaigning in my own constituency but
also touring the country as well helping
my colleagues get counselors elected I
believe in that absolutely I believe in
democracy we all believe in democracy
and of course when we're out there week
in week out
on the doorsteps and you know this you
are the ones on the front line facing
the criticism or what's going on in
Westminster responding to the tough
questions dealing and hearing with the
anger and frustration often the
disappointments of the public and
recognizing as well and we should be
honest about this and I think today has
done this that you know at the center of
our party they need to also be out there
much more listening as well and I think
Paul Paul being here today is brilliant
because actually it's all about hearing
from you listening and meeting people
because if we're honest as well and I've
been in government you know when you're
doing those pieces to camera or going on
those highly organized visits or taking
a few questions from journalists at
press conferences that is no substitute
for the hard graft the hard graph that
you all put in on the doorsteps the hard
graph that is required knocking on doors
campaigning day in day out delivering
Leaf layers because guess what my
friends that's what wins I suppose it's
not just pieces to camera and as
Grassroots activists of course we are
the ones who listen to and engage and
often face the consequences of some of
those bad decisions and also the
infighting that we have seen in
Westminster and of course if the center
of the party spent more time with us
listening engaging then I think it's
fair to say we would not have seen over
a thousand of our friends and colleagues
even lose their seats in recent local
elections and dozens of councils fall
out of conservative control
now I think it's important that we
discuss this because that's hundreds of
hard-working devoted and experienced
public servants no longer able to serve
and that's no fault of their own that's
also a huge loss to us on the front line
that's a loss of Frontline conservative
activists up and down the country
serving their communities now I am the
one of the first to thank them for their
service and I'm absolutely sorry that
actually it's the errors and the
mistakes sometimes of us in Westminster
and our actions that have cost our party
dearly across the country because some
of those whose seats will last may may
even be here today
and of course there are serious
repercussions and consequences for this
for the first time in 20 years my
friends we are no longer the largest
party in local government and that
actually has devastating implications
for communities in my view who are now
worse off without having local
conservative representation
so for us this is a moment of reflection
a time to learn and a time to rebuild
and I genuinely believe actually we've
got to stop this decline I believe I've
been married to a conservative
counselors obviously you know I
evangelize about this and sometimes he
would have said that's exactly why you
know we just need to be out there more
and more because if we're out there
visible working as public servants being
diligent public servants in our
communities then we will absolutely
ensure that the heart of the
conservative party remains strong and
active at the Grassroots and also
connected to the MPS and the party as
well
but of course we have to reflect upon
the last 12 months and we've heard this
today as well I know colleagues Jacob
and others have spoken about this
we haven't covered ourselves in glory
and in fact some parts of Westminster
and colleagues have done a better job at
damaging our party than the opposition
even the left-wing campaign groups the
Civil Service which you know we all
struggle with day in day out and even
I'm afraid some of those in the media
that want to distort and make life
difficult for us we have seen as
discussed today the Austin of a
democratically elected in fact our most
electorally successful prime minister
since Margaret Thatcher
and we should pay tribute actually not
just to Boris but to all of you at the
Grassroots because I'm no fan of
December general elections but if we can
have them again and again and get 80
seat majorities and quite frankly it's
worth it but we can only do that through
strong leadership and we can only do
that when Sean leadership motivates the
base which is all a few you know he was
a man that got brexit done LED our
country through a global pandemic and of
course delivered on the people's
priorities now I say this for an
important reason being democratically
elected matters it matters to us as the
party Grassroots but it also is
important to reflect that you know
colleagues in Westminster
by making the changes that took place
last year have also and we've heard this
today have turned their back on the
membership and effectively broken that
golden thread in terms of the Democracy
from the bottom of the party right up to
the top and we have to rebuild that we
really do and I fundamentally believe in
that I've spoken about this for so long
over the last 10 years in fact I believe
in demox citation in our party and it is
obvious that you are all angered our
members are angry about what has
happened and it has undermined that
famous Bond of trust trust has been the
word that's been used again and again
today that trust between our membership
and the leadership of our party our
party's reputation is suffering because
of that as well and we've been taking a
battery with the general public and of
course with that this has repercussions
on the pledges what we are who we stand
for all the promises and the
opportunities that we offered back in
2019 and now virtually being if they're
being Rewritten and that once in a
generation opportunity the people are
given and trusted us to transform our
country as Jacob said earlier on today
when it came comes to EU matters looks
like it's being diluted and frittered
away
and what at the end of the day radical
Innovative conservative Manifesto that
we all got behind back in 2019 which
reflected our values and our beliefs we
can't let that be confined to a corner
somewhere we have to stand up and
continue to Champion that and I think in
good news folks that's exactly why we're
all here today because we're committed
to rebuilding not just at a national
level but standing up and making sure
our voices are heard at the Grassroots
making it more democratic fighting for
the survival of our party and our values
and this is important because if we
don't no one's going to do it on our
behalf that is a fact
so to Peter's point we do need to take
back control and it is right that our
voices are heard and with that as Paul
has touched on in the debate just now
ensuring that we're heard the party and
its leadership are held accountable
through the Democratic structures that
John has been championing for decades
and I really pay tribute to John
Stratford John has been an inspiration
to me as well he really has and
I remember back in the day when I joined
the conservative party a long time ago
John was being spoken about then in
terms of democratic structures and it is
thanks to the convenient that we are now
able to talk about these reforms so that
our members have a greater say in
developing the policies a greater say to
select our candidates as was discussed
today as well for elections and not have
local associations just being imposed
upon and put upon again and again and
again and of course that is about
respect that is about that golden thread
and the respect between the party
nationally and the Grassroots
now all of this matters because at the
end of the day I've always said our
members are the most authentic voice of
the conservative party you stand up for
what we believe in you Advocate day in
day out our values matter more than ever
before and also in my view we do have to
stand firm on this because we risk
losing votes if we forget who we are and
what we stand for
our country faces some difficult
challenges and all countries around the
world are challenged right now the
consequences of a global pandemic
inflationary pressures and of course
we're now witnessing as well the impact
of Putin's war on Ukraine but look my
friends the solution to these challenges
is not more State Control it's not more
spending it's not more taxes which sadly
are featuring in our way of life right
now in the 1970s and 80s we Face
colossal economic challenges back then
and the solution was not more Socialism
or greater State Control in fact the
solution was Margaret Thatcher as we all
know the solution was robust
pro-enterprise free market property
owning democracy that Margaret Thatcher
promised and delivered that my friends
is the reason why I joined the
conservative party that is exactly why
you are all here today as well and you
were inspired to join the party
motivated to work for the party and
support the party and with that we must
never forget and this has come up again
and Mimi mentioned this earlier on as
conservatives we must never forget that
we are here to serve the public and do
so in a way in which that promotes
Freedom Enterprise and opportunity
because that's what separates us from
labor the public will not vote
conservative because they want higher
taxes High spending and high borrowing
though vote conservative because expect
us to keep taxes down back Enterprise
and defend Britain's hard-working law
abiding silent majority
so we need to get back on track to
deliver that historic mission of 2019
and unleash that amazing potential that
we've heard about today of the people
and of our country
and we are at our strongest and we know
we're at our strongest and our most
successful when delivering conservative
values and conservative policies in
government
and values matter because if we don't
stand up for values for Freedom
democracy for capitalism I can tell you
now as Kane has put it so succinctly
this afternoon bad ideas take their
place
history shows the terrible costs of bad
ideas millions of lies are extinguished
under fascism and communism and even
today many people still live in tyranny
unable to enjoy the most basic freedoms
progress is not inevitable and countries
can go backwards we see it with Ukraine
and Putin we see it with China look at
their presence in this country stealing
our intellectual property having its
spies infiltrate our Parliament our
public policy and our economy
undermining our values every single day
and here in Britain while Kia stalma
sorry while circus Dharma tries to
present himself as a moderate behind
that North London veneer the labor
benches in the House of Commons are
still filled to the broom with the hard
left Britain hating criminal supporting
socialists that wanted to see corbyn as
prime minister Britain forced back into
the UK and would cancel out of our
freedoms make no mistake if we don't get
a grab we could end up surrendering to
that kind of socialist nonsense and that
is why we must fight for our values and
it's not just about ensuring that our
party is successful we have to make sure
that our country is successful and
prosperous and the opportunities for the
Next Generation also come through
time and time again capitalism has
proven the best way indeed the only way
to live people out of poverty to raise
their aspiration while socialism has
failed and it is totally an utterly
incompatible with freedom
it's a nice people choice it strangles
creativity and when governments control
the economy they always end up
controlling and oppressing people in
other ways a government that tells you
how to spend your money will also tell
you what to say and how to think
and quite frankly given that we've now
forgotten the economic Facts of Life
it's no surprise that the bad ideas are
taking hold across our country and
institutions the left are pursuing their
own agenda of political correctness and
political correction as well as woke and
this is now resulting in our
institutions dominated by left-wing
groups parity nonsense on theories from
race to sex education to rewrite in
history and using this as a basis to
make policy
this nonsense and these distractions are
created by the left and it's obvious as
to why because starting arguments about
pronouns and work or banging on about
unconscious bias or debating what are
women at women is and telling us how and
what to think it's a lot easier for the
left than doing the really hard job of
governing and representing the people
and standing up for public service and
we are the ones that has to stop this
and we are the ones that have to call
out these bad ideas reject them and
stand up for what we believe in
summer friends the good news is and
there is plenty of good news we have
been here before and it is strong
conservative leaders that have turned
this around in the past when Margaret
Thatcher became prime minister she
showed what a strong conservative woman
could do and could deliver for Britain
and bring prosperity to so many
she brought back that same sense of
optimism and can do spirit that our
friend Ronald Reagan also brought back
in America they turned their countries
around and they took communism they took
it on together and they stood up for
those fundamental values that we believe
in
this is a similar moment it also calls
for strong renewed Democratic
conservative leadership
it is time for us to come together again
because hope has been in short supply in
recent months and years and we are the
ones from the Grassroots to bring it
back to the top of our party the UK is
the greatest country in the history of
the world there's no doubt about that we
must throw off these shackles of these
terrible bad ideas the indoctrination of
our young the work can cancel culture
that has been spoken about today and
ReDiscover our values that made us great
and the values that are still shared by
the majority of the British public day
in day out that silent majority that we
represent or we must stand up for a
belief in our freedom including freedom
of speech individual liberty and free
markets a belief in democracy and
friends that starts here and it starts
in our party by reigniting democracy in
our party and empowering you our
membership to have that say to stand up
for what we believe in to rebuild the
Grassroots it'll make our party our
government and our country stronger and
importantly it'll secure Britain's
Destiny as a beacon of freedom and
Enterprise and opportunity for all I
want to really thank you all for
everything that you are all doing and
Peter David Claire everyone for your
commitment you know the message is very
simple we do want to take back control
there's no doubt about that but we want
to ensure that our values are the values
that continue to inspire generations to
come again and again and again and that
the conservative party continues to be
that most successful democratically
political elected political party across
the world so we can see conservative
governments again and again run in our
country for decades to come thank you so
much for everything that you're doing my
friends it's great to see you today it
really is thank you for all your support
thanks everyone thank you
[Applause]
thank you so much pretty for a wonderful
barnstorming speech we expect of you and
uh it's great to have you here really
really good so
um ladies and gentlemen we that
concludes the first debate rebuilding
our Grassroots we're now moving on to a
second debate which is reconnecting with
Bruce